okay so this video we're going to
discuss photosynthesis its how
autotrophs can take sunlight can take
carbon dioxide and can take a little bit
of rainwater and through a very complex
series of chemical reactions produce
oxygen waste but really the prize of
photosynthesis our create is the
creation of sugars such as glucose so
let's get started so I'd like to direct
your attention to the electromagnetic
spectrum it's the energy given off by
the Sun and the visible light really is
what's going to power photosynthesis
invisible light is only a small portion
of the electromagnetic spectrum but
we're going to focus on visible light
given off by the Sun because that's
what's responsible for photosynthesis
well let's look briefly at how objects
either absorb or reflect light you know
that the Sun gives off visible light
white light colors of visible light are
actually a mixture of red orange yellow
green blue indigo violet so white light
the visible light given off by the Sun
is actually a mixture of these seven
colors here well how do I know this how
do we know that the visible white light
is all these colors mushed together well
if you've ever played with a prism as a
child if you shine sunlight in the one
end of the prism you can actually see a
rainbow come out the other end this
animation here shows what I just
mentioned coming in from the left we
have sunlight or white light and because
of the curvature of the glass prism the
individual wavelengths are separated you
can see that red has a wider wavelength
and the violets have a more narrow
wavelength proving however proving that
sunlight or white light visible light is
actually made up of a mixture of colors
you know we can often see something
similar to this just outside in nature
if there's moisture in the air you know
after its rained or in this case you
can see moisture of coming from a
waterfall but we can see that moisture
in the air kind of acts like a prism and
will separate sunlight into the
individual wavelengths producing a
rainbow so when we come back to how
light is absorbed or reflected well
first of all when sunlight shines on
this green leaf here again sunlight is a
mixture of all these colors the reason
that we see green in our eyes is because
green light is reflecting off of the
leaf the other colors are absorbing we
see the world as reflected light if you
see somebody wearing an orange shirt
orange is reflecting off of that shirt
the other colors are absorbing into the
shirt so if we were to shine sunlight
onto these bananas which color or colors
would reflect into the person's eyes
which color or colors would be absorbed
well if the bananas appear yellow that's
because yellow is reflecting into your
eyes the other colors are absorbing into
the banana well in this case again we
have some balloons now which color or
colors would reflect in which would
absorb if the balloons appear blue
that's because blue light is reflecting
into the person's eyes all the other
colors are absorbing well here's a fun
one right here here we have sunlight
shining on some snow and some trees
covered in snow but if you think why did
do that does do the trees appear white
why does snow appear white because white
reflects so all the colors are
reflecting and therefore our brain is
interpreting all of this incoming light
as the color white in this case none of
the colors are absorbing and so kind of
the opposite of white is black if you
know if light is shining on this
automobile the color black reflects
nothing the color black absorbs all so
when you see a black object whether it's
a shirt or an ottoman
you're really seeing no light at all no
light is entering your eyes and we
interpret that as the color black so how
does light reflection and absorption
relate to photosynthesis well most
plants have green leaves which means
they're going to reflect green light the
other colors however are going to absorb
and those are the colors that really
drive photosynthesis this graph right
here shows the wavelengths of visible
light and there's two points on the
graph where the line is the highest this
implies the colors are the wavelengths
that drive photosynthesis so around 400
nanometers we see a peak in the graph
and that corresponds the color blue
around 700 nanometers there's another
peak that corresponds to the color red
ironically the color that we most
associate with plants the color green
has some of the smallest or lowest rates
of photosynthesis so green light is very
poor in production of sugars however
blue light and red lights drive
photosynthesis so let's actually get
into photosynthesis now it's the
cellular process where sunlight is
converted into sugars and you've
probably seen this equation ever since
middle school to the left of the arrow
we have what are called the reactants
carbon dioxide and water are the
reactants or the ingredients required to
perform photosynthesis in the presence
of sunlight carbon dioxide and water
will produce sugar and oxygen to the
right of an arrow or what we call the
products it's what's the end result
what's created now this equation really
makes photosynthesis look pretty simple
but when we get into the details we're
going to see it's very complex well so
who performs photosynthesis well we
often mistakenly only think that plants
are the only photosynthetic organisms on
earth and that's just not true
autotrophs perform photosynthesis
and plants are just one type of
autotroph in the top right hand corner
there's a picture of kelp which is again
in the kingdom Protista the bottom left
our cyanobacteria which are bacteria the
bottom middle those are plankton
plankton are also a type of Protista and
in the bottom right we have algae algae
is also in kingdom Protista so there's a
lot of autotrophs that perform
photosynthesis besides plants so what
kind of chemical reaction is
photosynthesis it's what we call an
endergonic chemical reaction because it
requires an input of energy now the
picture should imply where the input of
energy comes from sunlight sunlight is
the energy that is inputted into
photosynthesis in order to start a
complex series of chemical reactions
known as photosynthesis so the end
result or the products of photosynthesis
again are sugar and oxygen waste you
know in this leaf if we zoom on in we
see these microscopic pores codes called
stomata on leaves and when the stomata
open and close they can release oxygen
into the environment they can take in
carbon dioxide from the environment so
the stomata are how plants can exchange
gas with their environment so let's look
at a quick overview of the chloroplast
or the site of photosynthesis you know
we can break photosynthesis really into
two processes the first being called the
light dependent reactions well if I chop
open a chloroplast I can show you that
there is these structures on the inside
and I've circled a structure called a
Granum notice how this circled structure
labeled the Granum is actually made up
of three individual units called
thylakoids
this is where the light dependent
reactions occur this is where the
photosystems which are groups of
molecules to capture and transfer energy
so this is where the photosystems
ultimately are going to help to create
oxygen ATP and a molecule called NADPH
the other stage or prime
that takes place during photosynthesis
it's called the light independent
reactions this really occurs in the
fluid-filled interior called the stroma
and this is going to be the location
where glucose is created let's go ahead
and jump into it so here's a picture of
our chloroplast again and if we look at
a much simpler version of a chloroplast
here is on Granum made up of 3
thylakoids well let's zoom out into one
thylakoid yep so now that we're inside
looking at a file a coid we're ready to
start the light dependent reactions if
you're in my biology class I've broken
this animation down according to the
diagram in our textbook so follow along
at step one in our textbook so what
happens is notice how in the membrane of
the thylakoid there's an object labeled
ps1 and ps2 these are what are called
the photosystems
so first of all there is chlorophyll in
the photosystems photosystem 2 is going
to absorb sunlight and the chlorophyll
that's inside of photosystem 2 has
electrons those electrons become excited
and what that means is that the
electrons jump into the actual thylakoid
membrane this causes the thylakoid
membrane to become negative negatively
charged if you remember electrons have a
negative charge to them well once the
thylakoid membrane becomes negatively
charged this is going to start what we
call an electron transport chain it's a
chain reaction of a series of events
triggered by all these electrons so now
look at area to an area 3 in your book
diagram and what we're going to show you
is that water molecules are going to be
broken at the top of the animation there
are three molecules of h2o water and
what I'm going to show you is that
hydrogen from the water is going to be
pulled into the thylakoids
there are enzymes I didn't picture the
enzymes in this animation but there are
enzymes that will break apart the water
and allow the hydrogen to be pulled into
the thylakoids there's a reason of
course the
this is all happening the photos
photosystem two just lost a bunch of
electrons in order to keep this process
going photosystem two needs to have its
electrons replenished so the electrons
of those hydrogen's are going to go into
photosystem two to replenish the
electrons that it previously lost
ultimately notice what's been created at
the top oxygen waste and so the oxygen
will be released through the stomata of
the plant and into the environment and I
think that's kind of cool that oxygen
that we breathe used to be part of water
molecules so moving on into the next
area of the light dependent reactions I
want you to focus your attention on PS
one photosystem one case you're
wondering the reason it's called
photosystem one even though we're
talking about it second is I think
photosystem one was just simply
discovered first so photosystem number
one just like photosystem number two are
groups of molecules that it contains
chlorophyll there's chlorophyll in
photosystem number one and when sunlight
strikes photosystem one the electrons of
chlorophyll become excited and just like
we saw a moment ago the electrons enter
into the membrane of the thylakoid the
thylakoid membrane and this is going to
continue our electron transport chain
the chain reaction of events that takes
place because of all these electrons so
moving on to the next step of the light
dependent reactions the electrons that
are embedded in the thylakoid membrane
along with various enzymes are going to
help bond a couple items together
there's a molecule with the full name of
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
phosphate we're just going to call this
molecule nad P so the molecule nad p and
a hydrogen ion are going to be drawn
together by the electrons in the
thylakoid membrane and various enzymes
and when they're drawn together the nad
P and the hydrogen are going to bond
together
make a molecule called NADPH now the
notes say NADPH is a hydrogen taxi you
know taxi is designed to pick a person
up at one location and drop them off at
another NADPH is called a hydrogen
carrier or hydrogen taxi it's going to
pick up a hydrogen and it's going to
take the hydrogen to another location
where it will ultimately play a role so
when we go on to the light independent
reactions in a few moments we'll see the
role of NADPH so when we move on into
the next steps of the light dependent
reaction I want you to see that there's
a bunch of hydrogen ions inside the
thylakoid remember those hydrogen's once
belonged to water and so now that
there's a high concentration of hydrogen
in the thylakoids they're going to
rapidly diffuse from a high
concentration to a low notice at the
bottom of the animation there's a little
tunnel or tube labeled ATP synthase this
is an enzyme protein complex here and
what what happens is when hydrogen
diffuses through ATP synthase ATP
synthase you can probably hear the words
ATP synthesis in your head ATP synthase
draws together an adp and a file an
appeal phosphate and when ADP is bonded
with a phosphate we have a molecule of
ATP adenosine triphosphate that's been
created well this happens a series of
times that ATP actually has a role to
play but as I just said this happens a
series of times so hydrogen comes
through ATP synthase and ADP and a P are
bonded together ATP is produced again
this happens multiple times hydrogen
flows through the ATP synthase and a
molecule of ATP is created this hydrogen
or this this ATP is really important
when we go on into the next step called
the light independent reactions before
we go into the light independent
reactions I want to summarize the light
dependent reactions
so it's called light-dependent because
it depends on light so sunlight and
water are going to be used to create
some oxygen waste but more importantly
to create molecules of ATP and molecules
of NADPH I want to point out that no
glucose has been created yet ATP has
been created and NADPH has been created
now we're going to see why those were
created let's move on into the light
independent stages so we can now begin
the process called the light independent
reactions also known as the Calvin cycle
named after the scientist who really
helped first describe this process it
begins in the stroma of the chloroplast
the liquid fluid-filled interior the
stroma and there's a five carbon
molecule you can see it in the animation
a chain of five carbons now it's
actually a lot more than just carbon
first of all this five carbon molecule
is called ribulose biphosphate I'm just
going to call it our ubp from now on our
ubp is actually made up of five carbons
and 12 hydrogens and 11 oxygens and two
phosphorus but for simplicity I've only
shown the five carbons chain together so
what happens is carbon dioxide from the
air will bond with rubp and when the one
carbon of carbon dioxide bonds with the
five carbons of rubp and the reason they
bond is again there's various enzymes
involved in breaking bonds and
re-establishing bonds and so this six
carbon molecule is now created well
let's move on to the next step so in the
next step of the light independent
reactions we have there the six carbon
molecule that was just created from
carbon dioxide and rubp bonding together
the six carbon molecule is going to
actually be broken down finally we see
the reason why ATP and NADPH were
created in the light dependent stage ATP
and NADPH are going to be used to break
apart that six carbon molecule that's
six carbon molecule is going to be
broken down remember when a teepee is
broken into a DP heat is released so the
heat from the breaking of ATP plus the
hydrogen of the NADPH plus various
enzymes that just aren't pictured in
this animation are going to break that
six carbon molecule into a couple three
carbon molecules the three carbon
molecules are called phosphoglycerates
or you'll just see them abbreviated as
pga so this process is going to continue
several times here's two more six carbon
molecules and the first one is going to
be broken down by ATP enzymes and NADPH
to create two more molecules of pga and
there's still one more in the animation
so here comes some ATP and nadph and
again with the help of various enzymes
the six carbon molecule were broken down
into two pga s so the amount of PGA's
begins to accumulate in the stroma so
what's going to happen with all of these
PJ's all of these phosphoglycerates well
two of them are going to bond with one
another with the help of various enzymes
to make glucose that's the whole point
of photosynthesis make glucose but what
about the other pga is the other
phosphoglycerates well they're going to
be broken down and recombined as well
with the help of ATP with the help of
various enzymes that i just didn't
picture those other
PGA's are going to be broken down and
recombined into five carbon molecules of
ribulose biphosphate rubp this is why
the calvin cycle is called a cycle rubp
marks the beginning of the next cycle
carbon dioxide will be taken in the
carbon dioxide will bond with the rubp
to make a six carbon molecule and now
we're just repeating steps previously
mentioned
so to summarize the light-independent
stage of photosynthesis carbon dioxide
from the air along with the ATP and the
NADPH
were made during the light-dependent
stage will be used to create glucose
which is a sugar now why does the plant
even need their glucose need the sugar
well the sugar that is created will then
be used during cellular respiration a
cellular respiration is another topic
for another day but that I hope explains
the connection between photosynthesis
and cellular respiration for those you
in my biology class this is going to be
your essay questions so very rarely are
you going to get essay questions in
advance we'll be talking more about this
in class so instead of the usual
practice quiz at the end how about this
instead I've given you seven steps of
photosynthesis in a random order try to
put these steps in order what comes
first what comes second third fourth
fifth sixth seventh if you're in my
biology class try this and bring me your
answers and I'd be happy to check them
for accuracy good luck
you